[Music]
Microsoft has announced the Dame time
for e3 2017 press conference and it's
not the usual Monday morning briefing
that the company has been known for
I'm Matt this is a GameSpot news update
and make sure to LIKE and subscribe so
you're set and ready for all the news
and reveals from e3 the Xbox Show will
take place on Sunday June 11th at 2 p.m.
Pacific this may be a different time for
Microsoft's conference but it's still
being held at the Galen Center in Los
Angeles xbox head Phil Spencer has said
in the past that 2017 won't be an FPS
Halo or Gears of War LED year but you
can expect to hear more about
Microsoft's next console project Scorpio
the system was featured in the tweets
and announced the e3 details you can
also expect to see more of the
open-world zombie game state of decay 2
developer undead labs confirmed that it
will have something to show at the e3
briefing we'll keep you up-to-date on
any other early announcement but for now
just check out our video on Bethesda's
upcoming shooter prey and how it can
scare you
with a trash can
you